okay ah good afternoon everyone and
thank you truly and thank you Mark this
is not here for inviting me to give a
talk here and thanks to the department
here as well as yci alright sorry it's a
real privilege to be here and I'm
delighted to do this presentation here i
thought i would pick as a topic trends
and extremes in climate and in part
because it's these are becoming such not
only it's the science motivation points
but also important points of information
into policy making circles concerning
impacts vulnerabilities adaptation and
mitigation so i thought i would discuss
this from a I come from a physical
science standpoint but I think there's a
lot of things to be learned in how
physical climate has to give information
and interact with the other disciplines
which are seeking information and
climate you see my name up there but I
have to confess that only a small
portion of the stock is really my work
or work i participated in a lot of it is
really coming from all the other gfdl
scientists but i think together it would
make a little bit of a coherent story on
what we understand about the climate
system in terms of looking at trends and
the extremes so i begin with you know
what's kind of Nava five-year-old thing
namely the results from the IPCC 2007
report but the trends are the indicators
that were identified in that particular
exercise were these various things
temperature over man increasing
temperature opposite increasing humidity
increasing sea surface temperature
increasing see is decreasing ocean heat
content increasing snow cover and
glaciers retreating so this form a good
idea of the trends that we were seeing
and there was assessed to be the state
of the art knowledge back in two
thousand seven so I'm going to actually
elaborate more on
some of these items and actually cover a
couple of things that were probably not
very familiar back then but we now
descend them to be part of the trends of
a warming world so picking up from five
years ago and coming to my institution
particular gfdl where we were in the two
thousand sun framework was it is pretty
much the pictures that you see above
here or couple of them and we were also
some of the results that fed into the
IPCC we participated in model
simulations which went into those
results but since that time to
particular things have happened which
have driven us in the direction of the
arrows that you're seeing here one is
the resolution aspect and the models
that we had and most modeling stations
had at the time of the AR four were
roughly 200 kilometers in horizontal
resolution and since then the desire to
get more information on finer scales has
driven the signs towards seeking models
with higher spatial resolution and
you'll see where that that is godness so
far on the other hand there's also been
a desire to capture more realistically
the processes happening in the Earth's
system be it at mistake chemistry
aerosols by geochemistry and so that has
been another driver now ideally you
would like to marry the two and come out
with the highest resolution possible the
most complex system possible but that is
that may be a solution but just from a
very pragmatic view point it seemed to
us this is five years ago that we go to
March a little bit in a calibrated
fashion towards this ideal goal of the
highest resolution in the most complex
model and seek instead intermediate
pathways whereby you're advancing in
this direction and in that direction and
try to see what more can you learn
relative to what it was five years ago
so let me go into trends part of my talk
and I want to talk about this model that
we have cm3 as it's called couple model
three we've assembled it for the world
fly mate research program seemed of five
those are the model intercomparison
experiments and also they are feeding
into the IPCC ar5 and in particular I'm
going to talk about this business of
greenhouse gases vs. aerosols how have
they changed climate or what is our
update on the knowledge concerning the
concerning the relative effects of
greenhouse gases and aerosols so one of
the things that I want to first
described in terms of the model details
that we wanted a particularly capture
was was two things and basically the
these and all the shortlist species and
then interactions of climate one was the
whole business of Shalott collared gas
phase chemistry which not only
contributes to climate methane of ozone
etc contribute to climate forcing but
also the air quality issues because one
of the things that was that the
questions were being asked is the
impacts on air quality due to the same
agents that force climate change and
then the other issue was trying to get
at the whole aerosol climate
relationship including the very sort of
nebulous effect of aerosols in clouds or
aerosols interacting with clouds and
altering cloudy skies and what they do
two things like surface fluxes these
mixed layer deep ocean etc so we want to
capture these two things both of which
pertain to the short-lived species
effects and so we basically came up with
this model which is shown here
schematically where this is the big box
doing atmospheric chemistry in a couple
model and fed into it our emissions of
precursors of various pollutants also
depleting substances which are which of
course have their effects in the
stratosphere and then other inputs are
the insulation the well mixed venous
gases volcanic aerosols and then of
course you have the traditional acoustic
dynamics and physics components
involving convection etc and then there
were changes some chain land model ocean
sea ice model i'm not going to go into d
tears and all that I'd be happy to
address them after the talk and these
were some of the changes that now
resulted so basically it was a very
similar looking model that compact last
time accepting there were more levels
and I'm not going to go to details but
there was a improvement in the
convection scheme and that's what it
means been of this updated moist physics
and one of the things that you always
want to inquire into is how good is a
model doing with respect to present a
climate parameters so one since one
going to focus on the aerosol issue I
decided to put these plots up which
shows a comparison if you look at this
particular plot it shows a comparison of
the optical depth in the model aerosol
optical of the model versus measurements
araneta some measurements and this is
the older model which was circa 2006
this is a newer model 2011 and the
correlation coefficient is listed here
which goes from point five four two
point six eight and the right panel you
see the comparisons this is a relative
difference with the arrow net sites and
I think you know I look at the numbers
but there are brighter red spots and
brighter blue spots then on the lower
panel which means that the lower panel
has actually improved in terms of its
simulation of the aerosol optical depth
and the the correlation coefficient here
may not seem like a big deal it's
certainly not as it's not something not
a very big improvement but it's going
the right direction and the key thing is
this was a model in which aerosols are
not interactive they were prescribed
calculated from an offline model and
then input in the climate model in this
way in this one it is actually
interactive and online with the
meteorology so in that sense this is not
only doing a more realistic handling of
the process but is actually also
improving the optical property
simulation in the model another sort of
comparison with with observations is
that of tropospheric ozone and this
happens to be three sites in India at
different
it's different place in India show you a
seasonal cycle of ozone and you can see
the comparison between the red and the
black is is rather rather than nice it's
very encouraging that the model is able
to reproduce it although there are still
details that happily captured and it's
not a completed story yet alright so
what is this model give in terms of
response to the various forcings over
the 20th century for the global mean
surface temperature so what is plotted
here in the black line is the observed
global mean surface temperature anomaly
over this period which is eighteen fifty
two thousand and the there are two sets
of lines here the the ok ignore this
this this curve is what you get if you
if you ask the question supposing well
miss greenhouse gases co2 or zone a co2
methane and two over the only gas is
forcing the system what would you get
for the climate system you'd get a rapid
warming which looks like this and then
you can ask other questions like what
happens if you forced it only by
tropospheric aerosols then you get a
curve like this and the green one
represents the effect of solar and
volcano and the blue one is with all the
46 now just to compare the blue and the
black which is the observed you see that
there is a it's not exactly matching the
observed in fact although the trend in
the last 30 years is about similar this
really has a very large sensitivity to
volcanoes so that the model gets really
depressed when when it gets hit by a
volcano and then just for comparison's
sake so this is the observed trend over
the hundred years last 18 years this was
what the trend was in the previous model
but was remember a model which had
lesser realism in our view then the blue
one but the blue one underestimates the
observed the other one over estimate the
observed so the the good news is that
you can use at least two different
models to serve to examine kind of how
different species under different
assumptions have forced the model but
the kind of unhappy news is that
is not exactly on the dot which you
would have liked it to be but
nevertheless you know there is the last
30 years the warming is significant just
like it is in the observation now so I'm
going to actually now that was a global
mean I'm going to switch to the tropics
and this is actually a simulation for
South Asia for the different component
so this is the all forcing always means
its force but natural and anthropogenic
agents this is if it was forced by the
lumix greenhouse gas only this is
tropospheric a result only and the key
thing both in the global temperature as
well as a salvation temperature
representation is this large opposite
sign amplitude that you see for the
greenhouse gas at troposphere carousel
which is very striking that in the end
in the last 30 years the greenhouse gas
effects is certainly dominated over the
aerosol effects in terms of temperature
change as you can see by the net result
but it is really interesting that the
offset is actually become an important
component driving the surface
temperature and this is looking more
closely into South Asia for the
different components this is the all
forcing so that's kind of the result
that result that that is there at the
end the greenhouse gas only is again
forget about the numbers but it's strong
warming and it's a strong cooling and
the volcano effects actually do act
something to the end of the 20th century
temperature change so as far as the
temperature is concerned the story is
very much similar to what was obtained
before even though the models realism is
supposedly has improved but the result
is pretty much similar in terms of
aerosols offsetting greenhouse gases now
I want to sort of dwell on the
precipitation over the South Asian
region so first of all looking at the
observations or i should say numbers
culled from observations and then
friends have been formed out of that so
this is a june july august amor rainfall
trend millimeters per day over the 50
years this is a CR you record this is
the this another record I forget now
where this comes from and there's a
university of delaware which is
these two are actually quite well-known
and the fourth one is the Indian monsoon
rainfall record now looking at these
figures the thing that strikes you is
there are there's a lot of areas of blue
which which means deficit in rainfall
anomalies in rainfall negative anomalies
in rainfall and the sea are you Delaware
and this data set actually show a very
pronounced decrease particularly in this
north central Indian region which is
kind of the breadbasket of India this is
where most of the agricultural happens
and it's a very it's also very populated
regions so the economics of the region
are very become very severe when there's
a drug or whether it's rainfall deficit
now the Indian monsoon rainfall is only
one which does not show a very strong
negative trend but there are lots of
questions about how the trend actually
has been evaluated using the discrete
discrete data from the different
stations compiled in this particular
plot it's actually unpublished flawed
but nevertheless it's the only plot
which doesn't exactly which doesn't give
the same magnitude of decrease as this
one the other three but by all means by
also knowledge it is well understood
there has been some decrease I think the
magnitudes are the ones that probably in
question now in terms of model
simulations of the phenomenons this is
the plot showing the effects of the
various forcings on the rainfall
decrease over the last 50 years first of
all the observed trend and the
background or the kind of curves but if
you look at just a linear trend this is
the observed and all forcings is a red
line here so that's going like this and
then if you have greenhouse gas only
vinos gas handles on that nose like this
and then there's a natural which is a
yellow which is going like this and then
the aerosol is the green line here so
first of all it is actually striking
that the aerosol curve and the
greenhouse gas where are
opposite the trends are exactly opposite
this one Rena's gas alone would actually
cause an increase in rainfall there and
that's actually well understood from a
lot of modeling studies done straight
from the 70s which shows that a monsoon
alaria rainfall has to increase and tell
you the reasons why it's basically the
simple reason is more moisture in the
atmosphere in a warming world but then
the aerosol one goes in the opposite
direction and the it's the sort of the
red curve which is all forcing actually
follows much more the aerosol trend than
the greenhouse gas trend and it's very
close to the observed or reasonably
close to the observed track so the most
important implication is that the
temperature changes show the greenhouse
gas dominating in the net result whereas
in the case of precipitation it turns
out of the air source yes yes everything
so this is an epidemic aerosol thank you
a frenetic aerosol which means we are
having black carbon organic carbon soot
I'm sorry black of organic carbon
sulfate nitrates and plus there is the
aerosol indirect effect in which organic
carbon black carbon and sulfur eight
participate so yeah this is regional
this is South Asian region this is this
box this is this box here more
elaboration yes so this will be
compensated by more precipitation
elsewhere it's not quite evident I
actually don't know the answer that but
it's not so evident that there is
necessarily an increase somewhere else
in the tropics it may be an increase
outside of the tropics that I am Not
sure all right so why does this happen I
mean this is kind of why does this this
seemingly aerosol dominance in the
precipitation happen so we can search
one explanation by looking at this plot
here which is an indicator of the
radiative flux perturbation due to
aerosols so what this is doing is
comparing just the radiative flux
change including the fast physics and I
will turn a little bit of detail but the
basic point here is that the aerosol
introduction creates a top of the
atmosphere reduction of about minus 2
watts per square meter globally and the
surface reduces of minus 3.6 now the
surface reduces because there is
actually less solar flux coming to the
surface and one of the things evident is
yet absorption the atmosphere there is a
strong absorption the atmosphere but
there's also a strong surface flux
deficit and notice that most of it these
blue guys are big chunks most of it is
north of the Equator there's very little
south of the equator that's because the
little aerosol suddenly quit it most of
it is Northern Hemisphere so just
schematically explaining this if you
take climatology and we can just
consider we can distill is down to two
simple things I Hadley circulation the
Walker circulation so this is the Hadley
circulation this sort of latitude no and
then this is kind of along the zone
tropical zone the Walker circulation so
that's climate ology now if you add
greenhouse gases what happens is the
greenhouse gas is actually weaken the
water Walker circulation so you can see
that schematically they weaken the
Walker circulation but simultaneously
another thing happens that water vapor
content in the atmosphere increases
because you're having more evaporation
so that tends to moisten the atmosphere
which tends to then dump more press
prism so that's why precip increases you
know in a sort of a very simplistic
fashions it's priestly increases in the
tropics in the greenhouse gas case in
the air assault case well they actually
tend to go in opposite direction in
terms of Walker circulation so they kind
of enhance the Walker circulation but
that's a small effect that's not a very
big effect the major effect is the
reduction in the Hadley circulation and
that occurs again sort of in a
first-order sense because you have lot
of deficit of flux solar flux hitting
the northern hemisphere southern
hemisphere practically is unaffected so
the reduction of the flux in the
northern hemisphere
essentially lessens the diabetic heating
in the northern hemisphere now one thing
that we notice nor model is although the
most of the aerosols are located in the
continental regions and a lot of it of
course is over Asia but this is not just
a local effect it's a sort of an entire
northern hemisphere southern hemisphere
asymmetry by the northern hemisphere is
cooling down because of the surface flux
inside not coolio northern hemisphere
has less diabetic heating southern
hemisphere has more I mean southerners
has no change so that tends to
decelerate or gives the Hadley
circulation which then reduces the
precipitation and so this is the
composite picture which is pretty much
dominated by whatever is coming out of
the earth all stories so the greenhouse
gases don't have the analog to the
hardly circulation change in exactly the
same way there is a hardly circulation
change but it's much smaller than what
the aerosols from industrial
pre-industrial times to present a appear
to have introduced and now I want to
sort of harp on this a little bit more
this Hadley circulation change arising
out of not south asymmetry not northern
hemisphere southern hemisphere symmetry
there's actually another model result
but it goes way back this is actually
work that was done with a pre ancient
model now called the Manavi climate
model done about 15 or 20 years ago
actually or 16 years ago where that time
you know we didn't have very good
formulation of aerosols the model we
just get a simple experiment where we
argued let's just do an experiment with
greenhouse gas plus an albedo change due
to a proxy mimicking sulfate aerosol is
equal to zero in the global mean but all
the Earth's all is a northern hemisphere
greenhouse gases global so what you
would get when you have global mean
forcing of 0 is you don't have any
change the global mean temperature but
you do have northern hemisphere not
wanting so much southern a masseur wore
me a lot but the most interesting thing
that we noticed was a precipitation
where if you did just a greenhouse gas
experiment that is this curve here so
you know basically not much of much
changing the precipitation obito kind of
gives you this very short drop
we have decreases precipitation just
north of the Equator increase in
precipitation to solve the equator and
the combination whether you add the
responses individually or I do a
response a combined forcing gives you
pretty much the same result so in this
experiment also it was essentially the
northern hemisphere southern hemisphere
a symmetry in diabetic healing that was
giving pushing the itcz especially
southwood yet another experiment was
done recently with pretty much the
similar model as i showed earlier on but
but coupled to a mixed layer rather than
a full ocean and again the same effect
happens where the gas effect on
precipitation is this the aerosol effect
is this and the combined effect is the
same striking conceptual the same
striking result which is that the not
northern north of equator it is pursuing
less salt the equator intercepting more
and here I have to add that these are
actually turn out to be not resolved
depend by any moral because these are
results that have also been obtained in
the context of the lgm simulations where
you have ice sheets in the northern
hemisphere and basically they reflect
more so they're causing a reduction in
diabetic heating and that tends to have
the same effect it pushes the ITCZ
southward and essentially the same
effect happens in an experiment I just
saw recently that in a swim showed where
she was doing an opposite thing where
she was doing an experiment on or
foresting the temperate latitudes are
not so you know you're actually now
adding deciduous forests or not it's
lies lies experiment but one of the
things that happens is that you reduce
the albedo in this case it's going the
other with the albedo is decreasing in
the northern hemisphere so if this
theory were to be valid you would expect
the ITCZ to move northwards it does
happen that's what I saw couple of weeks
ago from her model resolved so it seems
to hang together that these asymmetric
diabetic perturbations caused by any
forcing agent not just aerosols seems to
have a very discernible effect on
tropical precipitation which i think is
something to to self-analyze more in
detail now there's another interesting
aspect to this which happens if you are
looking now into the future so now into
the future so here we are two thousand
and if you look in the future these are
all the different scenarios so this is a
historical radiative flux perturbation
and then you consider the different
scenarios 2.6 4.5 these are different
amounts of co2 so they go the
conventional way in terms of radiative
flux because you're the greenhouse
trapping is increasing but the scenario
is about aerosols those this way so here
we are in 2010 something and the
aerosols are supposed to decrease which
is why the radiative flux perturbation
is fast approaching zero so aerosols are
decreasing the atmosphere co2 is
increasing so one of the things that
happens a temperature change is that
because the aerosols have been holding
like a thermostat they are being
offsetting greenhouse gases suddenly
remove that then you get warming so this
difference that you see here and this is
for a particular scenario this
difference you see and 2100 is because
of the fact that the aerosols were drawn
out of the atmosphere yeah why are they
going to decrease that's what the
scenarios seem to think based on client
based on air quality and health reasons
countries in Asia especially are
supposed to decrease I'm sorry because
you won't be able to change that's the
projection so if that is so then you
would see actually an accelerated
warming more than just you to greenhouse
gas alone and in fact that warming is
exacerbated in the mid-latitude northern
hemisphere including the Midwest United
States it seems to get a large bang out
of reduction in Asia but the more I mean
that's a this something that is well
understood i think we're now from you in
the previous IPCC reserves but the
precipitation one is an even more
interesting thing now this is an
extension of the previous curves on
precipitation but going beyond 2000 so
and this is for a particular scenario I
think this was our CP 4.5 so you know
here you are in the before 2000 where
greenhouse gas increase is going like
this and this is with all the forcings
and this is due to errors are only
showing how the aerosol is controlled
the precipitation up till now but if
this assumption that we've been making
about the asymmetry between the two
hemispheres and tropical precipitation
is even partially correct then what
should happen as the aerosols go to the
atmosphere is that this has to go back
up because now it has to be dominated by
greenhouse gases in the air so if the
anthropogenic aerosols are supposedly
going out of the atmosphere so that's an
interesting test I think it's very
interesting to see how how this really
works out in the real world if it
doesn't we have to go back for another
explanation for the 20th century but
this is sort of intriguing challenge
that lies before us now just
generalizing on precipitation trends
another thing that I think we have to be
looking for in terms of detection
attribution is just the overall
character of precipitation change as you
move into the 21st century so at the end
of the 21st century the projections from
the last type eccr that these are the
trends you should see in all the seasons
the southern portion of us would see a
deficit rainfall and the northern side
should see a increase in rainfall
because the whole moisture process is
moving forward there's a northward
movement or a forward movement and so
you should see that and so this is
actually another a sort of a
precipitation pattern that that that we
have to be cognizant of you know which
is kind of in respect of aerosols
because this is something going to
happen when greenhouse gases become so
much in terms of forcing then this
pattern again happen alright let me now
jump to a different topic change the
flavor here to talking about extremes
and what what can we comment on on the
extremes in terms of recent developments
in Earth in that Lane Society for more
modeling science so that three things I
want to take up atlantic hurricane
activity heat waves and just the group
intercontinental content or transport of
pollutants so first of all i want to go
back rewind the clock to three four
years ago when we are still dealing with
scene of three and a are for results one
of the experiment were one of the
experiment was done was where there are
sort of a downscaling of sorts where
results from global climate models were
downscaled into a high-resolution model
so essentially global models were
downscaled the domain of this size and
then that was downscaled further to
hurricane model size which is of the
order of work eight kilometers so you're
doing like to dance Kaling's to see if
you could simulate the tracks of
hurricanes using outputs from global
climate models or basically that would
be inputting the sea surface
temperatures and their large-scale winds
around this box and then this box
applies the winds to this box and of
course these are run for short time
periods so that you're not violating
boundary condition constraints in any
way so what this gave as a result was
the following so this was done with a
bunch of models outputs including Hadley
center and car gfdl Max Planck and so
the story out of this which came up
which was published in 2010 in science
was that the changes in a hurricane
frequency or 21st century would be
something like this where category one
two three hurricanes decreased in terms
of the number of storms per decade but
Kat the silliest ones four and five
increase so this was actually quite an
interesting result that you had the
severus category increasing in number
but the less severe category is actually
decreasing in numbers actually the total
number of storms really showed a
decrease but the most severe ones shown
an increase so this is about four years
ago with model with model outputs which
are in the 200 kilometer resolution
range now of course we have been able to
develop high resolution global models
and one of the tests for these models
not a sufficient test but nevertheless a
test is how well are they able to
simulate orographic precipitation
because our ography gets resolved as you
increase resolution so consequently you
should expect better results and this is
kind of a set of results that came out
very early in the development of
hydrological models at gfdl showing
compared with observation so this is
actually it's not exactly observation
but its data put together from
observations this was a model that was
there in a or four and you can see that
and these are models which are forced by
observed SST so that's why you get the
precipitation right place but it's a
pretty diffuse pattern that occurs in
the lower resolution models and as you
crank up the resolution there's a 50
kilometer model and this is a 12 and a
half kilometer model you actually start
to get really better and better
representations of the orographic
precipitation and this is western US in
djf of course this is something that you
know it's not surprising because people
have known this from simpler models and
studies that if you increase the
solution capital e or a graphic envelope
you're going to do better but now we've
applied this to other parameters other
variables so this is the mean northern
hemisphere sea-level pressure and what
you are seeing is the range of results
from the a or four models including the
gfdl atmosphere model which is in green
here and then the higher resolution
models are so this is 50 this is 50
kilometer and this is 25 kilometer and
actually 2015 20 to 25 doesn't go down
from 25 goes back up for reasons that we
don't understand but this is the annual
this is the various seasons but by and
large relative to the range of the a or
four results the higher resolution
actually seems to be improving things at
least in terms of this variable and we
look to others like final millibar
geopotential height so this actually
encouraged us to go further yeah sure
there was supposed to make sure that
your allergy so this is ok so these this
yeah what you're looking at is the model
forced over the I think it was a 20-year
period 1982 to 2002 or 85 2005 and so
you're forcing it by the unsub
climatology the SSDs and then you're
looking at the ends up results for the
sea level pressure that's the right
thing it worked and so this is a
comparison with whatever observation
that is of the sea low pressure how much
here there is in the atmosphere so right
unless it's a particular forecast or
something it's hard to know what that
you're you can't be less representative
out of here so it's come yet another
kind of that's my mother care measures
so no no I try to think I'll thinking of
this as a climatologist equipment ology
so you're forcing the model and with a
climatologist article SSTs and then
looking at what the what the atmospheric
pressure is I think I'll try to think
about it and get back to you okay so
this this is encouraged us to look at I
at further looking at it further so what
what this part is showing is the 25
kilometer model and this is actually
simulating northern North Atlantic
tropical cyclone frequencies or
activities number of storms is here
annual number of storms and then with
this is a plot versus here and the radar
the observations and blue is the model
ensemble mean and the way that this
model this modeling work was done was
initialized as a first of July
so you are initializing the model first
of July including anomalies and then
just letting them and then keeping the
SST is fixed and says he's not changing
and then you just let well ssds cheney
but so we'll bring the annual cycle but
the same bias as our first of july or
say anomaly is the first of july and
then tell you the model run and do its
thing and generate storms what is sort
of a very remarkable is the agreement
that you get in terms of the number of
storms generated by the high resolution
model we didn't get this when we were
working on with the low resolution model
we never got a result like this and this
actually is the 50-kilometer version but
the 25 kilometer actually does there's a
very neat job in fact in statistics
appear on this plot here is the same
plot as before accepting now you're
seeing the herbs in black and the red is
the mean with the bias removed and the
pinkish dots are the actual mean so
basically that there's no difference
with a red in being accepting for a
small overall crashing bias but their
police uniform throughout now the
correlation coefficient for the entire
period in terms of number of stars it's
point 88 that's just unbelievable
geophysical thing that you can get such
a high correlation and over the last 10
years it's even better is point 9 for
now the thing that we suspect what is
capturing this is really sum of two
parameters which seem very fundamental
to determining whether or not is a
cyclone in the Atlantic or a tropical
storm in the Atlantic and that is one is
the Pacific's one is their tropical
basin temperatures mainly the Pacific
sea surface temperatures and the other
one is the Atlantic temperature the two
together seemed to as long as you
capture them well which you can if
you're using n sub observations then it
seems like you can actually March to a
results like this which is really really
it doesn't say anything about tracks
landfall and so on those are different
things entirely but the frequency is
seems to be pretty well captured by this
and this now has now
to another set of downscaling
experiments where outputs from the
global models in the Sinop archive are
inputted into this model so the SST saw
those more input that is run the same
way and what you see here are two sets
of results 1 4 seam of three and this
one is a newer results for seen at five
and these are various models inseam of
three and you can see that it's not much
you can say about what the projections
would be at the end of the 31st century
it seems a mixed result and then you go
to see with five and now these are only
the gfdl models we haven't gotten around
to the other models but they're for
different scenarios here and this seems
to be giving a different picture both
from our models which are the couple
model I showed earlier and then a
different class of models called your
system warrants in which the carbon is
interacted with climate but they seem to
give well if you can three or a four
seem to suggest an increase in storms
but there is kind of an awful of line
off track number here so we got to do
this with all the other models but this
seems like an interesting steady are an
interesting set of results for the
projections in the Atlantic hurricanes
using high-resolution models now I
switch gears again to come to heat waves
so with the same model because of the
resolution it affords you can actually
go into the the topic of heat waves and
what this is showing is a comparison
from 1980 22 12 2008 the model
temperature or the Midwest so this comes
out of a out of the atmospheric model 50
kilometers in a solution force by SSTs
corresponding to this period 1980 2008
so you've got a got a very good
representation compared to the
observations although the the amplitude
is a bit too large and accompanying that
is the drawing that that you see and the
model again has a little bit as a sort
of almost like us uniform result across
the entire
eastern half of the u.s. the
observations don't have that kind of an
amp cured but nevertheless there is a
coherence that's evident and this is
actually related you can we track to
meteorological conditions we look at sea
level pressure surface wind from model
and observations and the locations of
these maximum and minima in the 500
millibar geopotential height this will
pretty much squares up with the
observation and sets up a kind of
coherence that then you know it suggests
that you can actually go forward and
quantify the the so-called heat wave our
heat wave is defined in a certain way
and I could exactly forget the technical
definition but it involves a lot of
parameters such as it has to be above
some of the normally has to be above a
certain temperature for three days in a
row it has to hit the 10th percentile in
warm temperature and so on but
nevertheless you know just accept that
what I have is really at the real heat
wave and just one defined by WM oh yeah
no no I'll going to other areas I'm
started in the Midwest because it's an
easier place to explain things but this
has been done for other regions and
around the globe it's being done for
Europe and Asia too and in each case the
kind of picture that I showed earlier
this one you can you can sort of really
discern it everywhere wherever there is
a so-called heat wave this is proceeding
the definition of a heat to it all these
conditions this happens in all economies
they are not what oh yes yeah yeah I
mean no no this is this is this is the
past this is the 1982 to 2008 period yes
I'm sure the project what happens pretty
but first let me go through the present
what happens so using this then you go
and do time slice and other points like
20 we took that 20 30 SSDs from the
couple bottles 2090 SSDs not putting 70s
SSD to the couple models and again drive
the high resolution atmosphere to get
similar statistics okay I've come it has
a question three slides later if you're
on the same question this law okay so
now this is what is happening in the
nineteen seventy one to I misspoke does
actually seventy one or two thousand so
for all that Midwest area so this is the
severity which i think is the extreme in
anomaly and then there's a duration of
days just how the sort of number of heat
wave days for you arrived at you have
duration in days you have a number of
events such events per year and you
multiply the two you get the number of
heat wave days per year and this is the
observe a shin or that same time period
so it is this kind of comparison between
modern observation that we are taking to
establish a basis for looking at the
future and this column represents the
period 24-year 2017 so basically over
this period the SST is from a couple
model were input into the high
resolution model and so by the same
analysis of the media logical events you
get at a duration which is now increased
the number of events per year has
increased so a number of heat wave days
per year goes up by a factor of about
three compared to the present period and
then when you go to a so this ratio
there's a ratio of 20-40 won 27 t vs 70
or 2000 and you are increasing the
number of heat wave days by a factor of
now when we look at other regions you
actually find tend to find out coherence
in the manner that's indicated here
whether the colors are backed up you
stand to see a coherent pattern when you
divide up regions in this matter in the
observations and then you look at the
model simulations that's what if that's
that's what the coherency appears as and
then so you can do a similar analysis
just like for the Midwest the Midwest
results are here duration number of
events per year and the heatwave days
for a year you can do the same thing for
each one of these regions all the way
from western to the eastern US and even
into Canada and so everywhere you
actually get a factor this is the ratio
you get a factor which is of that at
least three so it's three times more
heat waves per your heat wave days per
year compared to the present and if you
look at it self again with a
zeroth-order what is happening is the
warming of the surface northern will not
American land surface warming is
essentially by one degree gets you one
hundred percent change the number of
heat wave days that's how it scale says
so every 1 degree centigrade increase is
giving me some or increase summertime
one degree centigrade increase is giving
you one hundred percent increase in the
heat wave days per year and I don't I
didn't I didn't add the the other
regions like Europe and Asia to this
they are in my slides I can show them
later on but basically that they also
give the same kind of result and
increase the number of heat wave days
per year which is at least a factor of 2
greater in the 2480 2070 time period a
good question it is not as much as a
factor of 2 it's less than effective
till the South American and the South
Africa regions I don't know what
Australia that's you know I should we
should look at Australia Australia must
be more but Sal's Nalan hemisphere is
kind of showing all the landmasses are
showing pretty uniform factor of three
or
increase okay so now my final example is
actually climate chemistry so in this
case again the hydras initial model was
used in a slightly different manner the
50-kilometer model was used to which is
this bottom panel here was used to in
conjunction with chemistry a full of
chemistry module as I described earlier
to and the models essentially nudged to
global forecasting systems U and V
fields and then with full interactive
chemistry what was done was to find out
about the transport and the fate of
pollutants during a particular time of
the year now this timescale was this
period here may the month of May 2010
when there was actually an experiment
performed by NOAA called the calyx
experiment along the west coast of the
u.s. basically went all the way from
kind of San Francisco about san fran
suppose here and the sword went from
almost northeastern Pacific through
central France San Francisco through to
Los Angeles and there was extensive
measurements both from satellite as well
as from balloon sands and other
ground-based measurements and the same
solemn so they used two models one was
the course of the initial model that
that I talked about before which had
which had the full-on interactive
chemistry and the other one was this
high resolution model 50 kilometer so
one of the things that the model does
this is now the high resolution model it
shows this intrusion of ozone coming
from the stratosphere and you can see
that it actually goes all the way to
about a couple of kilometers that's a
large chunk of ozone hundred ppbv and so
the the key point you know in connection
with this talk is really a comparison of
this with the observed measurements so
this is showing the balloon observations
and this half of a particular day among
in that in that sequence may 28 and so
you can see the measurements I
this is sort of all the measurements
sites and they are listed here and so
this is a transect versus altitude and
you're seeing the blob of ozone coming
down on that day or this is a picture on
that day that's the course as racial
model which is wanting to you know spin
it off but just doesn't sort of get just
as it sort of get very very sharp
whereas the hydrogen model seems to do
better in this regard in actually
getting it down to lower altitudes and
the so the interesting thing about this
is that you had 100 ppbv just about 34
kilometers above the surface in Southern
California in a densely populated region
I mean that's a really if of course this
was a single event in the feet in the
course of this campaign but if those are
events which are happening more which
happen if they happen more frequently
when that is actually going to call for
reassessing air quality surface air
quality in these densely populated
regions that's really very very large
chunk of frozen ok so so that's that was
my third example of an extreme so let me
go to my summary slide at very basically
wanted again harp on two particular
points one concerning the trend the
other concerned extreme so in comes in
there in terms of the trend I think
we've been so used to looking at surface
temperature changes that and I think
that's a pretty nice record of how well
we have done in trying to simulate 20th
century global mean temperature that
even continental scale temperatures
surface temperatures but I think the
next order of business is actually look
at the digital precipitation patterns
particularly those induced by aerosol
effects in the South Asian region now
how robust are these results what are
the different models killings that would
be interesting to look at and then of
course the fact that the trend would be
reverse in the near future if these
anthropogenic aerosols were just not
there and along with that I'd also cite
the spatial movement
in terms of precip anomalies as we move
towards a more greenhouse gas dominant
world when the lead rat when the
precipitation should move forward and
then in terms of the extremes this I
think it's encouraging that these
high-resolution models with more
realistic physics are actually capturing
reasonably the the extremes or what we
do or maybe more appropriately defined
as anomalies from the mean departure
mean in terms of severe impact events
and that is certainly something that is
going to be important when regional when
people interest in regional impacts are
asking for climate information I think
we have a very good tool or a very good
basis to actually set about answering
that question so I'll stop there and
take questions thank you very much